[Music]
british iranian aid worker nazarene
zagari ratcliffe has been sentenced to
another year in jail by an iranian
courts
sakai ratcliffe had been released from
prison in march after serving
five years on charges of plotting
against the government
well her latest jail term comes from a
new charge of spreading
propaganda against iran she and her
family have always denied
the allegations against her well paul
brennan
is live in london joins us from outside
the
iranian embassy paul what's happening
with these
latest charges she's been accused of
plotting against
iran presumably from inside a prison
cell what's going on
well no it's um the reason why we're
here is because it's here
that uh nazim zagari ratcliff's
alleged offense is supposed to have
taken place uh
2009 uh in in anti-government
protests here outside the iranian
embassy naznagari radcliffe
participated in protests and gave an
interview to bbc
persian and now 12 years on uh the
iranians have decided to prosecute her
for this despite the fact that she's
already gone through the
uh system for the other charges um which
she denied
she denies these charges as well but on
march the 14th
in a 20-minute hearing behind closed
doors they
tried her for this offense and have now
decided that she will be sentenced to
another year
in prison i have to say that she's not
been ordered back to jail
yet so technically she's not behind bars
um the other aspect of it is that she's
not allowed to leave
iran uh for another year um her lawyer
has said that they will be appealing
against this verdict a time scale for
that legal process
hasn't been yet laid out but from here
at the iranian embassy i knocked on the
door just before we came on
air and i've submitted an email with a
request for a statement from them but no
statement has yet been forthcoming from
the embassy here
so what's this really uh about then paul
because uh
sagari ratcliffe's husband is very high
profile in his campaign to to get his
wife released and to
to to bring her back home essentially
has there been any reaction from him
does he think this is about a protest
that took place
on british soil or is there something
else to this
yeah now there's been plenty of reaction
and there's a lot of
uh conjecture and suspicion as to
exactly what is behind
all of this uh let's go to the reaction
first of all of richard
uh ratcliffe uh and he has said uh that
he believes that she's being used as a
negotiating
tactic by the iranian authorities and
he clarified that she hadn't yet been
summoned back to
actual prison the british prime minister
boris johnson has said i don't think
that it's right at all that
she should be sentenced to more time in
jail it's wrong that she was there in
the first place
and he said they're working very hard to
secure her release working with our
american friends
as he described them as well and dominic
robb who is the british foreign
secretary said it was totally
inhumane and totally unjustified this
decision by
the iranian court we continue to call on
iran to release nazim
immediately now as far as the why she is
there
well there are several different stories
um first of all that it's related to
an arms deal death of around 400 million
pounds an order for chieftain tanks that
was made
by the previous shah of iran and those
tanks were never delivered by britain
iran wanting at least their money back
britain
the british government has explicitly
admitted that there is a debt
that really does need to be paid the
question is how to pay it
there are sanctions for example that
prevent money being sent
in in such overt way to iran and the
british and iranians haven't yet found a
way
to have that debt resolved without
falling foul of those sanctions
the other aspect is of course just the
general state
of tension and diplomatic issues that
there are between
uh the west and iran um as regards
sanctions as regard the nuclear deal as
regards many many different things
okay paul brennan there live for us
outside the arena embassy in london
thank you paul